Hi, come on in!
This is the FDR suite
and our common room.
Well it's a pretty nice room. It's probably one of the
nicest rooms on campus.
Adams houses is one of the older houses but it
also contains
a lot of the old, what they call, gold coast dormitories
which were private dorms built around the turn
of the century that were very nice and only
the richest Harvard students could live in them.
So this is one of those dormitory complexes.
This is a shrine to FDR
and we put it together
the first few weeks of school.
This is FDR basically and the plaque that was here
when we moved in.
And this is our bathroom.
It's roosevelt's claw-foot bathtub
and his toilet, so he sat there and we
do now
and it's a pull chain toilet as you can see.
So you pull the chain and it flushes, and it runs
a lot but you know, it's old
almost a hundred years old so -- here we go
and it goes for a while--
not the most efficient fixture.
See, it's still going!
Then you have to make sure
that it refills by putting the stopper back
in place. We learned that after
couple weeks.
So, yeah that's the bathroom!
You get used to it really. (laughing)
So this is a letter he sent his parents about
his first week or so at Harvard, and talks
about visiting certain people
and looking for a room and so he mentions a lot
of the different
dormitories around here and
he actually
draws a sketch
of the room itself
in the letter,
and so you
you can see exactly where he stayed and where we are
living now.
He slept here--
where we were sleeping
and it adds that kind of human touch.
He was a college student too,
he studied too,
he worked on the Crimson too.
It does sort of add that connection
that was never there.